chaos tod und zerstörung dort schwere
verwüstungen in sechs us-bundesstaaten
seit dem wochenende wegen tornados sie
kommen in der nacht fegen mit ungeheurer
wucht über die usa fordern so viele
menschenleben und zerstören existenzen
mindestens 70 menschen sind gestorben
und die meisten davon in kentucky dort
stürzt eine kerzenfabrik ein in der sich
110 arbeiter befinden von ganzen städten
bleibt nur noch ein trümmerfeld kirchen
geschäfte gerichtsgebäude und etliche
wohnhäuser sind zerstört ja und bild ist
quasi am ground zero des sturm desaster
sin mayfield kentucky
das große aufräumen hat begonnen im mai
fiel kentucky dem ground zero der
tornado katastrophe die den süden der
usa heimgesucht hat es werden bis zu 100
todesopfer befürchtet und hier in
downtown fehlt sieht man nicht nur das
ausmaß der zerstörung an allen
straßenecken praktisch man braucht ihr
nur über die straße sehen ein kaputter
autoreparatur shop waren diese straße
hierauf war eigentlich eine der
haupteinkaufsstraßen und büro zonen hier
sind zahlreiche bürogebäude
eingestürzt habe jetzt gerade mit einer
art besitzerin gesprochen die nach ihrer
katze sucht die in einem dieser
bürogebäude eingeschlossen war während
der sturmnacht sie befürchtet natürlich
jetzt das schlimmste man sieht aber auch
jetzt hier bereits große großes
equipment bagger maschinen die hier den
schritt zur seite räumen es ist einfach
wohin man blickt eine szene der
verwüstung eine szene des todes wie
viele menschen hier ums leben gekommen
sind ist noch unklar klar ist die
aufräumungsarbeiten und die suchaktionen
laufen hier in kontakt mit vollen tempo
und es ist strahlender sonnenschein fast
ironisch eigentlich dass die natur nach
diesen horror den sie dieser region
zugefügt hat jetzt die sonne scheinen
lässt
und so geschaltet ist uns jetzt der
sturmjäger und wetter fotograf bastian
werner reist zu den gefährlichsten und
beeindruckten
wetterphänomenen der welt herr werner
ganz kurz vielleicht vorab noch mal wie
entsteht so ein tornado überhaupt ist
intern aber entschieden ganz bestimmten
typ des gewitters oder sogenannten super
zelle bei der super zelle treffen ganz
bestimmte scherben in der atmosphäre
aufeinander die sich in unterschiedliche
richtung bewegen und dadurch wird eine
zirkulation in der gewitterwolke erzeugt
die nun als endlich diesen tornado
entstehen lässt herr werner es gibt ja
wirklich beeindruckende bilder von
tornados haben wir auch gerade welche
gesehen von dem aktuellen in kentucky
gibt es gar keine bilder ist uns
aufgefallen wie so waren die sturmjäger
nicht auf zack
das ganze ist in einem gebiet passiert
wo normalerweise nicht sehr häufig
tornados auftreten das ist sehr weit
östlich in den usa das nächste problem
ist auch einfach stimmiger sicht man
kann dort nicht gut donnerstag war das
problem ist es ist sehr dicht besiedelt
und man hat dort auch sehr viel wald
außenrum das macht das ganze extrem
gefährlich für uns als sturm liga und
der nächste punkt ist es war nachts
nachts kann man diese ganze wolken
bewegung von im ton aber nicht wirklich
einfangen gerade wenn das tornados sind
sich auch in den regen entwickeln wo man
fast gar nicht mehr sehen kann das war
bei diesen tornado zeitweise der fall
das macht das gefährlich für uns und
natürlich auch dann für die leute vor
ort deswegen konnten sie auch
wahrscheinlich da nicht die häuser so
früh verlassen weil es dann gar keine
warnung in dem sinne gab
genau das problem den usa ist dass die
eigentlich immer tornados haben es gibt
eigentlich fast immer tornado warnungen
und da hat es drei probleme auf einmal
hat das erste problem ist es kann nachts
das zweite problem ist es kam sehr spät
im jahr und das dritte problem es kam
deutlich stärker als das die wetter
parameter im voraus gezeigt haben also
das war jetzt die tornados ist ob
beginnt im april und der höhepunkt ist
also im april und mai und im dezember
passiert da eigentlich nicht mehr viel
vor allem ich in dem teil der usa wo ich
sowieso nicht so viele kameras dann
auftreten vielleicht ja ganz kurz zum
schluss noch wie gefährlich sind
tornados für uns wie groß ist die gefahr
hier
tornado ist immer gefährlich das gibt
schwächere dollar das wird sehr starke
tun als das problem ist das kann man
optisch nicht einschätzen das heißt wenn
man irgendwann in tornau aussieht dann
auf jeden fall auf schutz suchen am
besten unten in den keller gehen und
dass ich oder sich flach unten hin kaum
irgendwo dass man halt geschützt ist das
gefährlichste sind immer die trümmer die
aufgelesen werden die werden nämlich wie
ja die geschosse werden die ich luft
geschleudert die perforieren dann
wirklich auch diese amerikanische
bauweise der sturmjäger bastian werner
vielen dank für ihre eindrücke
dankeschön